Hunter Henry missed most of last year
with a torn ACL that was suffered the
off season program he now has a tibia
plateau fracture that will keep him out
reportedly four to six weeks this is the
same injury Chris that happened to JJ
Watt a couple of years ago and I did his
season it happened fairly early but no
surgery no IR for a hunter Henry they're
hopeful he'll be back in four to six
weeks but this is just another example
of what happens to the Chargers every
year there's a not just one there's a
string of injuries and now they're also
worried about receiver Mike Williams
knee it's banged up and I don't know how
you can pinpoint what the flaw is in the
organization that causes these things to
keep happening but it just feels like
certain teams cannot keep their guys
healthy and I know there's luck that
comes into play yeah
but I think also at a certain level it's
more than locked the ability to keep you
guys healthy proper nutrition proper
hydration proper stretching proper
exercises proper recovery and rehab and
it just feels like there is something
missing there's a whole lot of something
missing with the Chargers because every
year they're in this spot
yeah and Mike I agree I mean there's got
to be something to it at the very least
listen it is bad luck a little sometimes
like you're saying and at the same time
it does seem to be reoccurring with
certain teams the Chargers you know the
Redskins went through a few years of
where you go gosh everybody's hurt all
the time and at some point you do have
to reevaluate what you're doing as an
organization you know not only rehab but
what you're doing maybe just getting
ready guys on a weekly basis then maybe
the training and the day after the game
everything that goes into training camp
there's obviously a little issue there
now this year I don't know you know the
good thing is we're not seeing soft
tissue injuries right that's where you
always go oh that might be something
with the way they're training the team
and all that this is you know a true
fracture of a bone it's just a little
unlike Durham and James the foot is a
fracture so maybe they have figured some
things out and they just got unlucky but
the very least Mike another player from
last year's team with the Chargers and I
know he didn't play last year but
another player they're missing is what I
want to say there's no Tyrell Williams
there's no Melvin Gordon there's no
Derwin James Russell all Kunz
not playing right now and now you have
this blow to the offense as well with
Hunter Henry it's just a lot to overcome
out there for the Chargers yeah and and
they just keep going right they make no
excuses and they just keep going and
that is what the good organizations do
they just find a way to keep moving on
no excuses next man up and you demand
the same level performance out of the
replacement that you did out of the
starter because if you allow that doubt
to creep in that that resignation oh
it's not our year that then it isn't
gonna be your year it's all gonna fall
apart and I think the Patriots set the
tone in that regard other organizations
have since figured it out but I think
that's the right attitude and with
Anthony Lynn is the head coach yeah
there is that accountability when it's
time to get a chance to play I mean why
would you be down in the mouth you're
getting a chance to play you're the
backup go do your job yeah that's right
and it is in the backup it's you know a
lot of times it's not them they'll be
ready to play they'll be ready to go you
just hope it doesn't filter into other
guys Minds on the roster too or the guys
that are playing with him like oh man we
got him in he's not as good or or oh now
I feel like I have to do more because
you know our backups in and he's not as
good as our starter I have to do more
and now you start doing too much where
you mess up your own job as well those
are little things you worry about as a
coach but you said it Mike Anthony Lynn
he's no-nonsense we've been around him
before he's not gonna let them make any
excuses or go cry to mommy I mean that
ain't happened in Phillip Rivers that
damn quarterback we know he's always
ready to fight so that's what I love
about the Chargers they're not gonna get
one thing I am worried about with the
damn Chargers is I checked the rule book
they're allowed to play run defense okay
because we've seen the last two times
we've seen the Chargers we've seen their
front seven get demolished whether it
was the Patriots last year in the
playoff game or a week one against the
Colts they are a running defense problem
right now in Los Angeles that concerns
me back to hunter Henry he had four
catches for 60 yards last week and he
actually did make it back for the
divisional round game last year when
they got spattered by Patriots he did
nothing in that game no receptions
nothing but he did make it back in play
after that torn ACL that he suffered
early in the
season and now we'll see when he comes
back and they say four to six weeks who
knows but when they don't put the guy on
injured reserve
yeah that's an indication that they do
have an expectation he'll be back
because otherwise you can shut him down
for six or eight weeks and then you turn
around and you add them back to the
roster later in the year so what and
here's the thing the question becomes
who's next
right how many more of these are going
to happen when does it stabilize it's
still early in the season you've got 15
more games to play
they can't take many more of these
injuries or it will fall apart for the
charges this year but they got their win
last week it won't be an easy test this
time around when they go face the Lions
in Detroit but we'll see what Anthony
Lin and the Chargers can put together I
still think they've got potential Chris
they can continue to win close games
that's the key they won close games last
year and they started this year with a
win in a close game now you're right it
is it's how they're the ultimate cardiac
arrest football team and you know
they've always been in these type of
games but the year you know two years
ago they couldn't make a field goal then
things like that that hurt them right
now they're pulling it out more times
than none
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports